it's time for roses and Rose a hi we're
keeping it 100 you guys
Rachel will not stop keeping it 100 I'm
going to keep it 100 with you and tell
you that this is the same Rosie I drank
last week it has an interesting face now
I love it
also I'm wearing workout gear because I
had to do some working out earlier today
because this body not a 100 whatever
okay episode number 3 of Rachel Lindsey
season of The Bachelorette was die nah
Mike
I freaking love this episode I have so
much to say as much as rachel is about
keeping it drama-free
these place are bringing the drama hello
boys Oh drama
drinks to the drama you guys practice a
little bit for my hair I say okay so
we're tearing down gender stereotypes
manner dramatic - cheers to that it's
2017
okay so last as we were left with a
two-seat continues and this is we
returned with Kumari Oh jamario gives an
apology that was not for the ages it was
like a 90s pop song he was like I just
want you to know I can't let you go that
I cannot let you go I was just being
caught completely off-guard
here's always great he tells Rachel
about how he had a conversation with his
Buber driver over right up here I
explained to my driver that I was going
for the woman of my dreams if anyone is
a therapist in 2017
it's an uber driver he said you know
what don't take no for an answer he
tells her favorite closest in order to
experience joy any pain and she's like
thanks for the quote but my boy
tell us guy that's Rachel sign is it too
late now to say sorry
sorry yes goodbye you know Mario keeping
it 100 100% truthful near Manos was keep
it room cheers every time Rachel key was
it 100 if you had been like Nolan Rachel
so then we have wah boom Walton and
Blake I mean really why boom tells
Rachel about this moment where Blake was
allegedly oh my bed peeling a banana
eating a banana and watching him he was
like licking the banana like this and I
love Rachel because she's always a
lawyer she's like did he finish the
banana
did the perp finish the banana Ben
Rachel sends in both all great
Rachel really is keeping it 100 you guys
because here's the thing she could have
kept wobbu wobbu and Blake around for
like more drama
but that's had plenty course it slipped
on a banana peel and it headed on out
that's crazy but they gave us some drama
to end it on of Blake's like it's time
to kill this guy now mr. Barracuda Bay
and Jeremy had this showdown which I
gotta be honest screams from both of
them like some kind of ploy to wind up
on paradise while boom even said there
does this thing about paradise and then
Blake was like how am I gonna live with
this I have to see him we live in the
same town Los Angeles a lot of people
live there gentlemen I'm sorry but
rachel is not here to play
so she said voiced by Phillips bullets
but okay how's it going oh then they all
go on Ellen Ellen is my spirit animal as
much as I love Ellen I don't have much
to say about this because we saw this
already on
it aired on the show what was really
funny was one that Alex guy admitted
during never have I ever that he peed in
the pool I love that that's honesty I
mean you want I was gonna keep it 100
you just admitted that you peed in a
pool there's City swims it and then we
had Fred oh my gosh this guy who Rachel
like went to camp with and he's just
getting really intense in his obsession
I think every time a guy was intense
about Rachel this episode because
there's a lot is a girl is so deeply
rooted like in my soul in my soul
then again drink every time we hook up
to 100 because she spent ride home this
book for boy by bullet I'm also gonna
keep one hundred and tell you I did not
wash this glass before this week's roses
and Rosie I rinse it out my wife's I was
paper not gonna have my desk I'm busy
okay oh speaking of that noise I just
made horses Rachel and his other guy
went on a horse date they wrote some
horses around Rodeo Drive in Beverly
Hills and not much to say about this I
liked him
I remember his name I thought he was
cool he seems really normal but the
thing is Rachel said and I quote this is
the lifestyle I could get used to this
Rachel keep it 100 do not get used to
this this is not real this is not the
lifestyle you're riding a horse around
on Rodeo Drive and it's things in like
Armani this is not life life is a you
and this suit is name I remember our
watching Netflix and ordering in on uber
eat okay that's why so let me see that
Bachelorette see just keep it
hair another I'm going to keep 100 again
you guys I'm losing a lot of hair I'm
worried then drink again every time
somebody's obsessive Rachael Eric I must
say what I have to say and based on her
answer I'm understanding where she's at
um Eric he's really intense Eric says I
got to read this because we were done he
says he's getting visions of Rachael and
that he's never been in a real
relationship
what what what worrisome oh but he knows
what he is bringing Rachel should like
him because he knows what he's bringing
what you're bringing is zero
relationship experience don't bring that
leave that at home okay so Eric from
here kind of progressively loses it more
and more
he says emotionally I'm involved with
the Rachel it seems to be all about
facade what and she's playing game
what never have I ever now we're
changing the drinking game you guys
never in rows and rows a we've done this
we're changing the drinking game mid
episode now the drinking game is drink
every time rachel says my girl my girl
my girl my girl because her girl showed
up raven grin and jasmine and Alexis are
here to help Rachel plan a date I love
all these girls her girl my girl show me
better big take your guys mud wrestling
first they're on this party bus with a
stripper pole and it's hilarious because
the guys like this is a test you know
these girls wants me to just hang with
Rachel for real on the stripper pole
okay detective Raymond Gates is on the
case Raven is using the party bus to
find out who is there for the right
reasons
good job Raven that's a good friend
that's my girl my girl
so there's mud wrestling and Dean's face
kind of said it all and Bryce literally
said it all and you look down and
it looks like it did it looks like horse
if it didn't look like mud I don't know
what it was made of but then it started
like taking and drying out all of them
and they all started looking really
scary also who was Bryce I forgot he
exists or maybe never knew he existed
but he gets real prominent at the end of
this episode so Alexis doesn't say a lot
but what she does say is worth saying
good job Lex and we get some shirtless
guys and the girls are wearing raincoats
for no real reason and alexis is
drinking champagne grade so the girls
are kind of winding down and talking
about who Rachel should be into and
they're into Dean but Corinne like he's
too young
good call Corinne Corinne is smart some
like them and so what I feel like maybe
I'm a threat to you guys no everybody's
a threat to everybody here okay so the
end of the episode winds down with the
boys just getting even more insanely
dramatic it's to the point where they
are seemingly taking each other out one
by one
Erik is like my name and then your mouth
seriously his name is in their mouths
get anything out of your mouth get out
of there get out seems like each episode
we are switching who is the villain who
is the hero who is bad either way that's
my girl that's my girl her name is rose
okay have a great night everybody
we are your every Tuesday make sure to
subscribe to ET on youtube and watch
roses and Rose a we're going to keep
rhyming because we got to finish out the
day just like jamario did except he said
goodbye and the limo and before we go I
got to tell you subscribe on YouTube and
bring the Rubik's Cube you thought I was
going to say Lu but I didn't but there
was a Rubik's Cube in tonight's episode
love you Hey
i Baba oh it looks like horse poop